[Musique]
le bus autonome c'est un projet qui a
démarré en 2020 jusqu'en 2022 sur la
ligne 393 l'objectif c'est que le Groupe
RATP continue améliore cette
expérimentation sur la ligne 910
le territoire Paris-Saclay on le sait
aujourd'hui que c'est un territoire
d'excellence et on est déjà en fait
acteur de ce territoire puisque à
travers la filière RATP cap ça claire on
est présent sur ce territoire on
exploite 44 lignes de bus depuis août
donc c'est un bus 12 mètres et donc
c'est un bus conventionnel sur lequel on
a rajouté justement une surcouche
autonome donc avec différents capteurs
qui ont été positionnés sur le bus et
qui permettent de comprendre et de
d'appréhender l'ensemble de
l'environnement qui est autour de lui
donc il a des capteurs de sécurité qui
permettent de pouvoir justement ralentir
et garder une distance de sécurité avec
l'ensemble des éléments autour de lui
mais aussi des capteurs de localisation
qui permettent de pouvoir se repérer de
manière centimétrique sur sa voix pour
être sûr d'être toujours sur sa route
lorsqu'il est mis en place dans de la
conduite sur ligne donc notamment sur la
ligne 393
c'est une première en Europe
effectivement il y a différentes
expérimentations qui sont mises en place
dans le monde par contre pour un
opérateur de transport et non un
constructeur c'est une première puisque
on met justement en place pour du
service voyageur sur une ligne
commerciale qui est la ligne 393 où on
en rajoute ce bus en renfort afin de
pouvoir justement
tenir le retour d'expérience des usagers
sur l'attente qui peut y avoir d'un bus
autonome
gros RATP souhaite améliorer cette
expérimentation bus autonome sur le
plateau de Saclay avec notamment la
ligne 910 l'objectif c'est d'offrir aux
voyageurs une partie du service en
autonome pour les Jeux Olympiques en
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]